today we are checking out the new pixel
3a this is the xl version and this
is the color purplish this comes in two
other colors there's clearly white
and just black and this is the xl
version which has a six inch screen and
the 3a
has a 5.6 inch screen there is a bit of
a price difference as well the xl
version is 479 and the 3a which is the
smaller version
is 3.99 but what's crazy about this is i
think that this may potentially be one
of my most
favorite budget smartphones and it's
crazy that we throw this word budget
around because phones now are getting
so incredibly expensive what you're
paying for a phone
is what we pay for computers like that's
crazy
so for this phone to be under 500 and
still have everything that you would
need and want especially an incredible
camera
is super exciting not only for me but
for all of you guys who are looking to
get a new phone
i know i know this is coming from
ijustine one of the biggest apple fan
girls there is
but i again always do have a second
device which is an android phone
and today that second phone is going to
be the pixel
3a xl
get out of here oops
oh wow it looks so pretty
the purplish
[Applause]
oh yeah oh it's so smooth another way
that they're making this more affordable
is by not making it have an all glass
back so it does have
this more plastic feel so it does make
it feel super light
like this is so light i love this neon
button
this is a great color and while this is
turning on let's talk about some of the
specs
so the rear camera shoots 12.2
megapixels you can shoot 4k
30 and then you can shoot 1080p up to
120 frames
720 up to 240. the front camera is 8
megapixels and
basically only shoots 1080p 30 frames a
second it features a qualcomm snapdragon
660 four gigs of ram and 64 gigs of
storage
the battery life on the 3axl is a 3700
milliamp battery and 3a is only 3 000
milliamps it does have fast charge but
unfortunately it doesn't have wireless
charging and i'm so used to having
wireless charging everything now
but to have a phone that doesn't have it
it's kind of it's kind of sad
i'm like please charge
it also has usbc and of course
a headphone jack so now
we're gonna set this up and then we'll
test it out
i can't be trusted i can't be trusted
[Music]
my favorite part of any new phone review
it is the camera test right now i'm
filming on
the google pixel 3a xl which is over
here
and this is the iphone 10s max so we're
gonna go out and take some photos take
some videos
and there's a lot of children around
so just we'll try to get out of their
way
[Music]
this is really good content i think i
have a new channel
i just streamed
[Applause]
front facing test over here iphone over
here
pixel xl you guys think i'm gonna put
this year but mate down for you you
are wrong but look at these ducks one of
the things i like testing out is what do
the cameras look like in different
lighting situations so right now i'm in
the shade
but as i move into the light how does it
adjust
does it adjust quickly and not adjust
quickly
so now it's time to take some selfies
one of the things that i love so much
about the pixel phone is the
front-facing camera has a really great
wide-angle lens so i'm going to take two
pictures here
first on the pixel and then one on the
iphone
these lenses are pretty much the same
distance from each other but that wide
angle view gives you
so much more to work with so now i'm
gonna zoom in
on the pixel
let's do a front-facing portrait
iphone forget
can you zoom with a portrait that's
interesting
okay that's so zoomed
that's actually really cool i mean this
is probably going to be my new professor
but i'm still surprised at how well that
managed to do
zoomed in wow good job good job goog
do you want me to take back camera
portraits yeah i don't i don't think i
could do it myself
[Music]
wow okay the color seems
a lot more vibrant in this one
seems to be a few more artifacts here
but the iphone did a pretty good job too
i mean honestly what drives me crazy is
we sit here and we nitpick
the smallest tiniest things like both of
these cameras
are beyond incredible and honestly most
of the phones you get today like you're
gonna have a decent enough camera like i
sometimes think i'm driving myself crazy
by just like trying to go in and find
out which one is better in which
situation
i don't know is this is this which one
is better what do you guys think
maybe we tried like a brighter light
situation
imagine if my eyes were open
okay i'm falling over
there you go
falling over again i got it right okay
yeah definitely more contrast in the
pixel
and uh it still looks a little a little
light a little more washed out in the
half and shot but like if i adjust this
though it'll be perfect
so if i go in here
i adjust like that black a little
unlike the contrast like yeah now
it's perfect what i do like is you have
a lot more to
work with there i love taking panoramas
so let's take one here and see
how it looks
it's processing i'm in such suspense
okay well i guess well that processes
let's take one on here
so the iphone panel processed
immediately
the google one took a few few seconds i
can't really tell because these screens
are super small so i'm gonna put them up
here and let me know what you guys think
which one do you like more
pixel or iphone it's not quite dark yet
so as soon as the sun goes down i'm
going to take a few night shots with the
pixel and the iphone because one of the
things that i'm so excited about and was
so impressed with the previous pixel
was the night shot so now we're testing
out night sight since it's finally dark
so i'm going to be testing it with and
without night sight so you guys can see
what it looks like with and without
[Music]
actually this shot that i got here was
also taking using night shot this is one
of my favorite photos that i took last
year it was of the moon rising over the
mountains and it was so amazing the only
phone that i had was my iphone
and the pixel but look how incredible
this turned out one of the things that i
love is ar
and there is a little playground here in
the camera app you can add different
types of ar things like this
little cheeseburger that i have just
dropped on the middle of the street
and if i hold this down i can record a
video
okay oh oh wait oh he's going where are
you going
are you running away from me oh my god
he's close to your foot
i'm making him dance oh my god he's he
is something else
can you see that like i what i'm seeing
it's not really there
now let me make a little video of them
like in the future this is what we're
gonna see
things that aren't really there there's
little pets there's japanese phrases
travel there are so many
this is wild you guys better be
following on instagram
because it's about to get wild so that's
a quick little look at the new pixel 3a
up against the iphone 10s max
i've really been enjoying this phone so
far it's only been a few days but i look
forward to testing it out a little bit
more especially testing out some of the
phones that have come out this year
there's already been so many that it's
extremely overwhelming i'd love to know
from you guys what phone has been your
favorite this year and what phone are
you looking forward to it's releasing
later this year
that's it for me that's it for you can
see in the video
so have fun have a good day
carry on